I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight now the
list of what qualifies as racist Grows
by the day
gas stoves English grammar mathematics
words like master bedroom and field
office can't say them and now we add to
that Automobiles and driving in general
a new piece by Sammy Roth and the LA
Times provides a window into the
insanity that is the modern liberal mind
the piece titled how white and affluent
drivers are polluting the air breathed
by LA's people of color
says that Mr Roth is racked by guilt for
how he's driving on the 405 to the
valley and it's not only growing his
carbon footprint
he's fueling other racist outcomes as
well
he said I couldn't help but consider my
own complicity while reading a new study
from USC researchers it found that
angelinos who drive more tend to be
exposed to less air pollution and
angelinos who drive less tend to be
exposed to more pollution
now the argument is that low-income
communities of color were torn apart to
make way for freeways over the decades
while The Wider richer neighborhoods
don't have to deal with the traffic or
the freeways this the left claims
constitutes environmental racism
environmental racism it's about policies
and practices that discriminate against
communities of color by making them live
near landfills sewage plants and other
polluting facilities well by making
people live near landfills or making
people live next to polluting facilities
well that's obviously ridiculous and
this is obviously not about race it's
about poverty
and who's to blame for the generational
poverty that has plagued minority
neighborhoods in the United States
liberals of course who thought that they
could replace the nuclear family with
big government that's who
the fact is their policies have failed
Black America on everything from crime
to the economy to education so now all
they can do is try to blame America
itself
in the practice of racial grievance this
has become its own sub-specialty
environmental racism while not always
the most visible form is also widespread
so when is enough enough
when is enough enough translation open
your wallet and get ready for
environmental reparations
blue states have already set up their
own offices of environmental justice
that end up harassing business owners
into forking over money and even land to
make things right
and leave it to Pete has made
environmental justice one of his main
priorities
what we're doing is we are reconnecting
people who may have been disconnected or
divided by discriminatory decisions in
the past I don't know why anybody would
be against reconnecting people who have
been divided by discriminatory decisions
in the past and again the point is not
to make America feel guilty the point is
to make America better and more
equitable
Equitable is just a buzzword for making
it easier for the government to take
money and opportunities from people who
earn them and then spend those monies on
sustainability projects that make their
donors and their cronies rich
also if freeways are racist the king of
bigots must be president Dwight D
Eisenhower who commissioned the
construction of 41 000 miles of Highway
in the Federal Highway Act of 1956.
I want you to meet the Godfather of the
environmental justice movement Robert
Bullard
when we talk about infrastructure in the
past infrastructure like highways and
Roads that infrastructure was
detrimental to many communities black
and brown communities and destroyed uh
stable community so we have to be
careful not to assume that all
infrastructure is created equal
people actually write those lines
of course what this is really all about
is control
Democrats don't have any real plans to
raise the general standard of living for
working people white black brown in fact
they're doing the opposite they're
wrecking our economy with out of control
spending and by limiting our oil and gas
sector
inflation and high prices
disproportionately hurt minorities
so all the Democrats right now have to
offer is a life where you have to get
used to living with less traveling less
having less
cars and the highways we drive on though
think about it they symbolize free
movement a land of endless possibilities
but let's face it the party on the left
gave up on America that America long ago
and if they had their druthers the
suburbs will become just one big
extension of the Cities
home values destroyed by high-rise
development for more Equitable Green
living
remember this was an important goal of
President Obama and you've probably
noticed the explosion of so-called
affordable housing projects going up in
small town America
that means bye bye suburbs and that's
the entire Point hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else